youtuber apology time why am I still
getting hey Cooper I have no idea how
I'm gonna record this video dude hello I
wanted to make a statement on what I
said to review youtuber apologies that's
right
for some reason I thought this was a
good idea you know I made a few apology
videos just a few of them just a couple
so I feel like I have the basic
knowledge and skill to determine what
makes a bad apology video and what makes
a good apology video so sit back and
learn just in case you become a youtuber
and decide to mess up in it as well like
most of us now what makes them perfect
YouTube apology a couple things there's
a couple things first up the most
important thing you need to start off
with a sign you need to tell your
audience immediately this is a heavy
video to make and it's an extreme burden
on your shoulders and there's no way a
better way to do that but with Messiah
number 2 what you want to do is shift
blame shift blame whatever you can do
okay
never take responsibility if you take
responsibility and that's submitting
that you're wrong and doing that that's
just impossible never admit that you
were wrong rule number one actually
that's the rule number one rule number
two shift blame rule number three play
the victim
you will you want to make sure that
people know that day this has been a
great inconvenience to you okay this has
been a big problem for you so you might
want to bring up something like let's
say I'm getting cyber bullied his entire
community has decided to cyber bully me
or if you're in deep trouble
you what you want to do is you want to
bring in death threats because basically
anyone that messes up on the Internet
will get death threats it's just how the
internet works
unfortunately there's gonna be that
0.01% of people that go too far and
that's an effective way to just diminish
every other criticism the 99.9%
everything else that I people have to
say excuse me I'm getting different okay
oh I messed up oh well a few selected
people have decided to send mean
comments to me so I think your point is
badly and I take full responsibility for
that every single one of your biggest
client told me how much money you've
taken from that moment you've heard that
like I maybe they'll say their names
like if you want me to I'll ask them to
ask you like I looked so why does every
single one of your clients tell me that
six months ago they knew that you were
gonna scam me that six months ago you
stopped working on all their stuff just
to make money off of me you know you
could always say that you take 100%
responsibility but then shifted
completely to someone else that's always
a good sneaky move to make maybe say
like you know what this was 100% my
fault that you were offended let's go
through the apologies I've selected a
couple I selected the most
quintessential apology videos that I
think has defined that the culture on
this website yes my own is included but
let's just jump into it first off we
have that tmartn apology video this
video sort of became a meme on itself
just because it is a goddamn piece of
art this apology video I mean T Martin
if this apology video was a fine wine it
would be an ocean to 1955 element very
good just to bring in context in case
you weren't aware of this I'm sure and
most people know but basically T Martin
ran CS go gambling website he pretended
that he had nothing to do with it and
look how much money I'm winning I'll bet
guys look how much I'm winning all right
kids sign up for my website where you
can win - and oh what it came out that I
own the website what I'm the CEO of the
website
what and here's the apology video so T
Martin thought okay well I need to
address this in the best way possible
Cooper I have no idea how I'm gonna
record this video dude
I can't stress enough I wish I loved
this video okay guys okay guys because
we're only eight seconds in and don't
really so much have happened first off
you start off with a dog that's an
amazing thing to do you want to bring in
like a pet something that everyone loves
everyone loves dogs and he doesn't just
bring in a pet he also has the pet for
advice I have no idea how I'm gonna
record this video and the dog even looks
sad I mean if this is not the perfect
apology video I don't know what is if
you can make it your pet looks sad for
your apology video you're done hey he
brings in the most beautiful sight I
have ever heard well diluted nostrils
his eyes are boys so he tells us you
know what this is me then you had the
background not only is he sitting in the
goddamn mansion you know if you scam
kids for money you kind of want to meet
seemed a little bit more subtle with it
maybe you want to not record in the
entrance hall of your mansion
how tall is that ceiling and on top of
it all how do you get your car in the
background of your video I'm sorry how
is that even possible
he does not only just get his mansion in
this apology video he gets his car in
there as well
a nice little cameo I mean I don't even
know how I could possibly set up an
apology video to have my car in the
background it doesn't get better than
this alright guys so well I'm gonna try
to make this as short and sweet as
possible I don't want to take up too
much of your time but first and foremost
I do want to say that I he started off
by saying that he doesn't want to waste
our time and then he proceeds to waste
our time with saying how much he loves
his fans I love you guys you guys
seriously mean the world to me you have
for the past 6 years that I've been on
YouTube and you honestly have changed my
life like every single day I get to wake
up and chase my dreams and follow my
passions and that's all been made
possible because I lied to you I'm sure
he loves his fans just in the same way
you love your money just in the same way
you love your car and your mansion so I
don't necessarily think he's lying I
just think it's
it's a good way to start a video you
want to make sure that you tell your
fans how much you love them right off
the bat but and not acknowledge any
wrongdoing that you've done just that
you have just so much love to give now
my connection to csgo lotto has been a
matter of public record since the
company was first organized in December
of 2015
however I do feel like I owe you guys an
apology I am sorry to each and every one
of you who vote like that was not made
clear enough to you I love this cuz he's
been exposed that he's company he was
the CEO of the company but there the
response is basically it was public
record it was just public it was it's
your fault get it shifting blame this is
what I'm talking about
it's your fault I'm not being
disingenuous and I haven't been lying to
you it's your fault you know you watch
this video go boys all right so I'm
gonna open up my it's your fault for not
understanding how perfectly clear it is
that he actually owns his website look
at that well through a hot start baby I
mean this whole apology really is just
it just seems like he's trying to cover
his ass legally speaking and he even
says it himself please also know that I
am committed to making sure that my
youtube channel as well as all of my
other businesses are in compliance with
the law they're in compliance with the
law everybody a great response you know
if you've done something that people
don't like just just hit them with that
it's a compliance with the law guys like
that ice cream of a kid it's a
compliance with the law so what was the
repercussion with this well not much to
be honest a lot of people thought you
know this would be a big scandal
possibly jail time people said there
will be millions of dollars in fines
what what was the verdict well basically
nothing I mean they got away with a
warning from the FTC and essentially if
this happens again they will be fined
roughly $40,000 which for someone like
tmartn seems like a pretty insignificant
amount so really nothing really changed
but you know it was in compliance with
the law as far as I can tell he saw
still uploading videos and I mean fair
enough I guess I
no there's no reason to dwell on these
things but I will always be grateful for
T Martin for the best apology video I
would rate this apology video
it's an 8.5 I know I just said it was
the best positivity of all the time but
it could be better
let's go through why we have of course
Laura Lee's apology video now I didn't
know who Laura Lee was apparently she
did some racist retweets it's just
confusing this video to me because I
don't understand what is going on does
it start does it honestly start like
this I wanna talk to you guys there is
no tears the video has just started off
if you want it like why Pat's here you
can start the video at any point this is
an amateur move what you want to do we
just say you want to make sure you get
to the point of the tear break then you
hit record you can't just you know what
what is this
12 seconds in and she said absolutely
nothing at all but rubbing her face in
strange way and fake wipe tears this is
this is good this is what I meant with
the white tee Martin's apology video
wasn't perfect because he didn't do this
this is what team I would miss missing
the thing is when you're going through a
controversy and the internet absolutely
hate you now I can speak from experience
although I never cried personally from
it because I'm not a child or a whamon
just joking you know it is a stressful
moment and I think that's what we're
witnessing here this is not an apology
this is a I'm trying to fathom what is
happening to me here I'm trying to
process what is going on right now this
is not an apology this is a reaction
video to the outburst that is probably
happening right now I imagine on Twitter
or in different news media
why is this so comedic I you know you're
watching someone crying you're not
supposed to laugh right but I think most
people think this is funny I don't know
why is it the rubbing I'm not buying it
I don't think anyone is buying it oh
Jesus Christ what was that was that from
the nose or the mouth or what happened
yeah oh you know what I'm sorry this is
the perfect apology so some people
pointed out the reason why she's not
really crying and then sometimes you see
tears this is stressed tears so she's
not really crying because she feels bad
but she's crying because she's dealing
with all these emotions happening which
is kind of aligns with what I said
earlier as well disappointed not person
she practically hasn't said anything but
I'm better so but haven't showed any
reason for us to believe why I don't
know maybe I'm being mean now I can't
tell but I just find it interesting how
she starts off with saying I'm better
I'm better now guys I'm cured look at me
I six years ago decided to retweet
things that were so vile what
laura-leigh does here is absolutely
amazing because when you mess up you
want to underplay it as much as possible
you want to make sure that people get
the lowest form of what you did so
instead of saying that she tweeted
something it was a retweet and she goes
very hard in on six years ago it was six
years ago how can you possibly still be
angry but that's the problem with these
things people don't really care when it
happened
stupid and I have no excuses here today
I'm not here to give you an excuse I
have no excuses I'm only here to say
that I've done this as well this is a
great you can't make excuses in your
apology video but it's just so damn hard
not to so what you want to say is I'm
not making any excuses but then you can
still sort of sneak excuses in there you
know it was six years ago I'm not making
any excuses it was a retweet
I'm not making any excuses I'm glad
there's captions here because I honestly
I don't know what she's saying
this goes on for four minutes and 44
seconds I can't I can't stay in this
video it's kind of like some things are
just so bad that they're good this is
just bad I'm sorry again there's no
excuse continues to give excuses alright
they've gotten her phone number they
attacked a child again I feel weird
criticizing this but I think it's an
important point it's not okay getting
death threats and I think everyone can
agree on that but it's not a valid
excuse either if you get death threats
take it up with a police there's no
reason to bring it up to your audience
as a tool of defending yourself I've
seen this done so many times even by the
media mainstream media as well oh we're
getting so many hateful comments or
death threats or people are being so
mean or yadda yadda yadda you know it's
sort of playing the victim mentality and
it's sort of saying that everyone that
criticizes me is doing this thing so
what was the replication here well
Lauren Lee was celebrating that she got
five million subscribers with the
hamburger
saying five and then the comments are
saying I'm confused on YouTube it says
4.4 meal
hmm this is very confusing yeah about
that boy do I have news for you
I think that's really the reason why we
got this reaction instead of an apology
because she was losing subscribers and
you know you got to pull the plug quick
you got to do something real fast if
that's happening I would rate this
apology video as solid set it's it's
pretty good
it hits most of the points that I
brought up earlier moving on we have of
course Logan Paul I'm kind of sick of
talking about Logan Paul but it has 53
million views this is the most viewed
apology video of all time which is
something I'm sure Logan feels very
proud of you know that was a joke but
it's true I've made a severe and
continuous lapse on my judgment the
funny thing I think the reason why I
love this apology video is that it was
you know he did the mistake of making a
tweet first when you're in the drama or
the internet is on your back you want it
you have to sort of assess the situation
you know it's just gonna grow bigger you
know are people not gonna just care for
a while like how far'd wage will go to
address this do I make a video
do I just make a tweet and Logan full of
thought I'll just make a tweet and it's
a beautiful tweet it's a beautiful thing
I'm sure everyone's seen this but here
it hits all the good points as well
instead of apologizing just make sure
that you can tell everyone how great you
are as a person you know how this is the
first time you've ever made a mistake in
your life
for example that's a good way to start
off an apology video how you get so many
views on your channel that this drama
doesn't even mean anything to you that's
always a great way to acknowledge it as
well how you upload videos frequently
and how hard you work on those videos
which has nothing to do with the
situation and then say how much power
and influence you had I mean where's the
apology in this it's absolutely
beautiful and I think the cherry on the
top is the emoji a good apology ends
with an emoji and a hashtag otherwise
it's not either wise don't even talk to
me about apologies hashtag Logan for
life but the video is pretty good III
you know obviously a lot of people hate
Logan but I you know he addressed that
he what he did was wrong that's that you
know what else can you do a lot of
people have been commenting that he's
clearly reading from a script'
and all these things and oh he scripted
his apology and I get that but clearly
you want to have some idea of what you
want to say this is usually a pretty
important video and you want to make it
right so I don't really see that as an
argument obviously if it's completely
script that it comes across as
disingenuous and maybe someone else said
it but overall I think that's fine I
don't know maybe that's just my opinion
no I did not script all my apology
videos okay I've made a severe and
continuous lapse of my judgment a good
apology video sounds like someone else
wrote it okay what you want to make sure
it's a use language that you don't
typically use in your videos so it
people can know that it's not you who
wrote this apology someone else did so
you can read it out I made a severe and
continuous lapse of my judgement which
totally doesn't say I want to apologize
to the internet when you make an apology
video you want to make sure that you
apologize not to the people affected or
at least not first you want to apologize
to that people that are angry first I
want to apologize to the Internet the
internet apologize to anyone who's seen
the video the people who see in the
video most importantly I want to
apologize to the victim and his family
and then the person the most important
one put that last that's the last that's
the last thing on the list I don't
expect to be forgiven I will be better
thank you it's a pretty good apology
video I I don't have that much else to
say about it but it would be better if
he ended with look in for life this is
my personal opinion if I had to give any
feedback if you guys need any help with
your apology videos always reach out to
me I I'm here to help now we're running
a bit low on time so I want to just give
a quick shout out to some response
videos we have of course jenna Marbles
famous 47 minute long what happened to
my fish's video it's a forty seven
minute long
apology video it is the Atlas of apology
videos a lot of people use this apology
video as an example when someone makes a
oh they did this horrible thing and they
just did a two minute response video
with jenna marble did something simple
wrong and she made a 47 minute long
video so if you were actually really
sorry
you may would have made a five hour long
video you would have made a 24 hour
livestream apology video if you were
really sorry I've just been seeing a lot
of people make this argument which of
course makes no sense I do like this
video it's really funny and it's a I
don't know in a bizarre way it's not
really an apology video it's just Jenna
giving an explanation to what she did
wrong apparently she bought fishes and
the way she treated them instructed by
the general store manager was incorrect
so people in the internet got angry that
this is not how you treat the fishes and
then she made a video responding to ok
I've learned and this is how you do it
basically I am that's I think at least
what I got out of it which is nice you
know because a lot of people don't know
these things and if the store manager
gives you the wrong information it's
nice that she took a chance to give the
Internet the right information as well I
mean obviously most people don't know
how to treat a face I mean we also have
the famous fine brother response video
which looking back on it's kind of sad
isn't it you guys remember this that's
over what this all is has been so
overwhelming and what we've realized is
that we completely screwed up with how
we originally because I mean I feel bad
I met them I know they're nice dudes
I've only met them once so I can't say
like yeah they're amazing like they're
legit but I don't think they had bad
intention but this apology video is just
so awful it's just terrible it's the
worst apology video it seems it kind of
comes across as their scolding you you
know they basically try to copy right
that's right can we copyright they
copyrighted the world react because they
own the YouTube channel react so people
are like no you shouldn't try and
copyright react because then you can
just copy strike everyone else I put
react in the title this is actually true
but they're saying no we're not going to
do that
even if that wasn't your intention you
shouldn't try and do that so it's just
some saying no you're wrong you're wrong
we're not we would never do this you're
wrong the thing is they're not youtubers
they produce videos they don't sit in
front of the camera they have other
people sitting from the camera for just
this reason so things could definitely
have gone a lot better they seemed like
you're doing fine now anyway so it
doesn't really matter it's one of those
things that really shows you in my
opinion how important it is to make sure
you do an apology video the right way
because then you know if your intentions
are pure that doesn't necessarily come
across in a video so I think this is a
good example of that so for example we
have a YouTube channel youtube.com slash
react so we're trying to protect it and
not run the risk of losing our channel
name thanks to someone else getting the
trademark but just because we have or
might get trademarks doesn't mean we're
going to run around and start taking
down videos you dummies I guess I got a
watch mine I mean I can't sitting
criticize other people's reactions and
not acknowledge my own first of all I
mean what is that cup doing there could
you not have moved that goddamn cup it's
so annoying to me I don't know why
second of all already the posture I mean
I'm clearly in a very different position
here hi guys sorry this is not how you
make apologies you see I still have
things to learn I also look a bit angry
I don't look very happy I'm no I'm not I
wasn't happy no surprise I wasn't that
hello I wanted to make a statement on
what I said in my previous livestream
you probably won't believe me when I say
this but whenever I go online and I hear
other players use the same kind of
language that I did I always find it
extremely immature and stupid and I hate
how I now personally fed into that part
of gaming as well this is true I still
believe this but I haven't given anyone
a reason to believe this at this point
so it's kind of stupid to bring that up
in the beginning I would say the thing
that I said in the heat of the moment I
said the word
now because I said the heat of the
moment that has just become a meme that
has just transpired through YouTube it
was a heat of the moment guys come on it
was just a heat of the moment you know I
didn't mean for this just sound like an
excuse but a 100% comes across an excuse
so I never should have said that and I'm
not gonna make any excuses to why it did
because there are no excuses for it
accepts you you basically just made a
bunch of excuses for it you idiot
a very good way to thank okay that's how
I should have started it honestly
whatever it doesn't matter at this point
it's interesting looking back though at
how different I feel I'm really sorry if
I offended hurt or disappointed anyone
with all of this being in the position I
am I should know better yeah I keep I
keep forgetting about that part don't I
how long ago was this not bad it's not
bad I think I'm doing okay I owe it
crops in here because you know when you
make an apology video you want to keep
the cuts as low as possible because if
you just if you have it a consistent
cuts in it and people are just gonna
think it's fake it's kind of like you're
reading off a script or something like
that
kind of like the Laura Lee video has
constant cuts in it despite you know
it's just being said nothing in it but I
wanted to make sure that the last bit
came across properly because I thought
it was important to say that you know I
don't want this to keep happening
because obviously this is the second
time I messed up big time and I want to
make sure that people know that I'm not
planning for this to happen again yes
there was the thing with the tweet okay
that was insensitive but it wasn't maybe
as big of the Alessa tease that this at
least one of the things that I've
learned from my mistakes is that there's
a clear difference in what mainstream
media or news outlet wants to think
about something and what people actually
think about something I was given so
much advice that looking back on I am so
glad I didn't take if you want to make a
good apology video just be honest
don't try and think that you can trick
the internet because you can people
people are smarter than you think and
they'll see through the whole
it's bullsh a it's easy to for me to say
this looking back of course but it might
be a good lesson for everyone out there
that's it for YouTube apology videos
there's clearly a lot more of them but
we're way over time so smash like
goodbye